so getting into Secret Wars part six in
truth this comic is actually a little
light on content in comparison to what
we've seen so far where issue number
four saw the death of Steven strange and
the dispersing of the various survivors
from the earth-616 and Ultimate Universe
continuities issue number six continues
the trend of their investigations into
what took place between the collapse of
the multiverse and the formation of
battle world under dr. doom picking up
three weeks after issue number five
which concluded with Thanos standing at
the wall separating battle world from
the Marvel Zombies and Ultron army issue
number six opens up with dr. doom and
Valerio Richards examining the bodies of
Corvus glaive and Proxima midnight
conveniently what Hickman does here is
give us a bit of information regarding
who these two are by way of Black Swan
to provide a little context for the new
people when dr. doom had begun the
process of attempting to defeat the
beyonders efforts to destroy the
multiverse
he had amassed an army to help with a
task which were called the black swans
as the sole survivor of the group this
woman took the name Black Swan as a
singular identity and along with a
handful of others survived the collapse
of the multiverse transitioning back to
the story we learned that over the
course of the last three weeks various
territories within battle world have
begun to rise up against doom and while
none of them possess the power to
destroy him outright their efforts have
been driven towards gaining the power
necessary to do so
furthermore despite having been tasked
with finding the surviving superheroes
from before the collapse of the
multiverse valaria Richards have been
unable to achieve this task but as we
discovered an issue number five she
along with several others have been
working against Doctor Doom to end his
rule indicating that she is most likely
lying here this sentiment is actually
compounded on when the story transitions
to the foundation as a group that
appeared during Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four and was actually referred
to as the future foundation the purpose
of the future foundation was to bring
the world's top minds together in an
effort to develop various technologies
to ensure a brighter future for the
world however when the collapse of the
multiverse happened the individuals that
we see here were the only members of the
foundation that seemed to have survived
furthermore because valaria has a level
of intelligence on par with both Reed
and doom while she had not figured out
everything that was going on at the very
least she speculated the doom had killed
dr. strange
than the survivors of our 6-1-6 and the
ultimate universe continuities as a
result she and the rest of the
foundation began to focus their efforts
on discovering the source of Doom's
power as well as putting the pieces
together regarding the battle that took
place resulting in the death of Cyclops
as the Phoenix the vanishing of the
survivors and the death of dr. strange
picking up with both versions of Reed
Richards from the earth-616 continuity
in the Ultimate Universe the
conversation between the two serves to
establish the dichotomy of their
outlooks on life and their moral views
for 606 Reed the defeat of doom would
likely result in his death which draws a
series of questions regarding what would
happen next however for the ultimate
read the only issue at hand is the
destruction of Jim with everything else
existing as a secondary now this as a
whole isn't wildly important and all it
really does is provide us with their
differing perspectives but also sets up
ultimate Reed to continue his role as
the villain the maker going into all-new
all-different marvel furthermore the
discussion between the two reveals that
the insurgency within battle world is
not a disorganized revolt among the
various territories instead someone
referred to as the Prophet is leading
these territories to freedom by helping
them to revolt and then defeating the
members of the Thor Corps when they
arrive to restore order in addition to
this we learn that 6-1-6 Reed is aware
that his wife Susan his daughter valaria
and his son Franklin served at the
pleasure of doom and while their
memories appear to have been altered in
a manner that keeps them from recalling
their lives before battle world on a
personal level six one six Reed
recognizes that unless Doom is defeated
he will effectively have lost his family
transitioning to Castle doom proper what
we find is that Peter Parker and Miles
Morales have been tasked with locating
the source of dooms power presumably by
Reed Richards however as the to
investigate the means by which doom
accesses his power the two were joined
by Valyria Richards who reveals the
access point in addition to this the
modification of her memories by doom are
confirmed when Peter recognises who she
is but she does not recognize him and
doesn't know anyone by the name of Reed
Richards and so the three begin to talk
valaria admits that she was willing to
help miles and Peter access the source
so long as they answer the question of
who it was that actually killed dr.
strange during the battle confirming her
belief that it was indeed dr. doom
valaria lives up
into the bargain and provides the tube
with the passage they seek descending
into the white-hot room the two come
face to face with Owen Reese providing
him with a hamburger that's been in the
pocket of Miles Morales for several
weeks
Hickman toys with us a little bit by
hinting at the idea that even if Reese
isn't Galactus per se at the very least
the hunger he suffers from is akin to
Galactus and that he consumed everything
that existed within the white space now
what the contents of this area was is
unknown and hatred never actually tells
us but when Pierre and Miles ask Owen
about the source of Doom's power Reese
responds that he himself serves this
purpose now again this is really Hickman
just leaving things ambiguous and will
most likely be revealed at the end of
the story but for the sake of having a
little fun I would hazard a guess that
when dr. strange Owen Reese and dr. doom
stood against the beyonders at the end
of everything because Reese had the
power to manipulate the molecules of all
things in existence he most likely
defeated the beyonders absorb their
power and now exists as a way for doom
to control that a world and so picking
up at the Isle of auger motor which
serves a doctor Strange's home
the story begins to get a little more
interesting when we join black panther
and name with a submariner after
entering the two are met with a magical
vision of dr. strange allowing him to
continue once they've proven their
identities by providing a password dr.
strange goes on to tell them that if
they're seeing this message is due to
the fact that he's died as such he left
his personal artifacts to only his most
trusted friends the first object is the
siege courageous unlike the siege
perilous which allows an individual to
step through and have their entire life
reset while being transported to another
location the siege courageous allows
transport in the same fashion without
the loss of one's memories the second
object however is far more powerful and
comes in the form of the Infinity
Gauntlet as he explains because
battleworld is a singular reality
composed of multiple other realities the
Infinity stones were pulled from these
various territories to form the gauntlet
which will work if it's used now picking
up with Susan storm and Franklin her
recollection of the events during the
early days of battle world come in the
form of a bedtime story but also give us
one interpretation of what has happened
beginning with the formation of the
Fantastic Four
the events that took place leading to
the development of their power
remains the same except that instead of
Reed Richards leaving the group instead
as far as Susan is concerned it was led
by her father Franklin storm now her
recollection of these events is most
likely due to dr. doom modifying her
memories to ensure that her recollection
of Reed does not interfere with her
perspective of the world as doom had
created it but as the story goes the
Fantastic Four existed on earth and
fought villains however when the
multiverse collapse took place and
battleworld came into existence the
environment was harsh and only the
strongest were able to survive amidst
the chaos during this time Franklin
storm had been killed and during the
pandemonium doom had appeared under the
desire to bring order to the chaos
however before we find out anything else
Susan ends the story and since Franklin
off to bed and so picking up with Thanos
the insurgency within battleworld and
the various individuals within continues
as we find him speaking directly with
Ben Grimm
during the conversation Grimm reveals
that when battle roll had taken form and
order was restored by doom because the
Marvel Zombies and the Ultron robots
were so dangerous and would ruin the
existence of everything else doom had
requested that Ben Grimm allow himself
to serve as the wall protecting battle
world from these threats
however founders this by stating that
this request from Doom was a ruse for
two reasons
the first is that with all the power he
possesses doom could simply eliminate
the Marvel Zombies in the Ultron robots
with almost no effort the second is
because like Johnny Storm doom felt
threatened the reason being that prior
to the collapse of the multiverse Ben
Grimm existed as part of the Fantastic
Four
and worked a forth of various schemes of
doom furthermore while Ben does not
remember any of this because it was
unaffected by the memory modifications
that doom employed Thanos does in
addition it seems that at some point in
the past Johnny Storm became aware of
what was happening and as a result doom
cast him into the sky to exist as the
Sun feeding on Ben Grimm's pride and
recognition that with anno says is true
the story comes to an end as Ben Grimm
seemingly abandons his role as the wall
separating the Marvel Zombies and the
Ultron robots from everyone else and
joins in the uprising against dooms rule
over battle world with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and keep in mind guys this comic
comes out once a month and
we'll be until November that we get back
into this with that being said I will
catch you guys later
peace